old age is inevitable and you can
imagine living past a hundred well into
Vincent's case 106 local Vincent shank
first caught our attention for being one
of the oldest living pow World War II
veterans well tonight Vincent's daughter
is remembering the life he lived after
shank passed away in his sleep this
weekend Madison Kimbrough is live in our
Newsroom tonight with his story I got
the privilege to meet Vincent Shane just
last month as I interviewed him for the
Veterans Day Parade upbeat spry and
ready to chat is how I remember him
tonight we hear from his daughter who
shares how lucky she feels to have been
able to live life alongside her father
for this long
he was my best buddy he made me laugh
every day he always said he was going to
live into his hundreds Nancy shank
remembering her late father Vincent
shank a World War II pow veteran we
interviewed Vincent just last month
about attending this year's Veterans Day
Parade he was 106 years old at the time
it turned out was fantastic
millions of billion people they were
grateful they all wanted to shake my
hand since his passing Nancy says she's
received an outpour of support Vincent
who started out as a first lieutenant
plane Navigator in the U.S Army Air
corps soon became a very successful
musician here in Vegas playing alongside
key entertainment figures like The Rat
Pack he was on the road with many big
bands and then they came to Vegas in 51
when it was a very small town and he
started playing at all the the hotels
here he played the trumpet and trombone
until retiring at age 65 in 1981. from
there he and his wife Dorothy would
split their time between Vegas and
Hawaii Vincent running his first
marathon at age 80. and while his health
was always his top priority Nancy says
even on his not so great days he led
with a smile and was always there for
others I know he always didn't feel well
but he would never let on it and he
always said the most important thing in
life is to help your fellow man
Nancy shares with us that her dad will
be cremated and buried at Southern
Nevada Veterans Memorial Cemetery in
Boulder City next to his late wife and
as for how Vincent lived for so long
Nancy says he exercised lived a
vegetarian lifestyle and loved juicing
in The Newsroom Madison Kimbrough 8 News
Now